[Music]
hey Wolfgang well just like I said in my
last video that I did yesterday Marta
was gonna put out a ton of trailers
before infinity war to get the hype up
for it and today's trailer did just that
with some new awesome scenes here and a
spoiler alert for those of you who are
trying to avoid them might not want to
watch this video also be sure to
subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date on Avengers infinity war we're
gonna need some help
hey big buck not bad for the end of the
world this Friday
[Applause]
[Music]
Avengers infinity war okay there's a lot
of new scenes here and I'm not gonna go
over each individual one because the
movie comes out in four days and I don't
want to give any spoilers away the first
one I'm going to talk about is the one
everybody's talking about right now and
that's the clip of Captain America
yelling go the first question is why and
who is yelling go - some of you may have
noticed the orange and purple light that
is on his left arm some people think
that this means that Captain America has
some Infinity stones but I do not think
this I think it's a reflection off of
thanasis Infinity Gauntlet because this
looks like the same scene where Captain
America is grabbing the Infinity
Gauntlet and Thanos just pressing down
on him so I have two thoughts here the
first one is that he's yelling at all
the adventures to attack Thanos I think
he's yelling at them to attack because
Stannis is about to attack vision to get
the mind stone and then my second
thought is he already has the mind stone
and he's yelling at vision to go to run
away there's so many reasons why he
could be yelling go so it looks like
we're just gonna have to wait until the
movie comes out but let me know why you
think he's yelling go in the comments
below the next thing is pretty simple it
shows war machine dropping a bomb we'll
come back to this later the next scene
is really cool because we see two things
we see Thea nose using the power of the
power stone and then we see some of Iron
Man's new bleeding-edge armor suit to me
it looks like Dana's is attacking dr.
strange because we've seen in previous
trailers that dr. strange attacks Thanos
and Thanos breaks out of a trap that dr.
strange platform and then attacks with
the power stone this is what I think
Iron Man is sitting there watching you
also noticed that Iron Man has wings
this is just a great example of his
bleeding-edge armor suits nanotechnology
how it can shape into whatever he thinks
of and clearly he needs the power and
the technology because he's fighting
Thanos on Titan in this scene the next
scene is Doctor Strange casting a spell
if you look very closely you can see
behind him Spider Man and Iron Man if
you look at their surrounding you can
clearly tell that they are not on Titan
yet so what I think this is is I think
it's Doctor Strange opening up a portal
to Titan to where they can go and fight
Thanos and the last scene is war machine
crashing to the ground
in previous trailers we've seen war
machine laying down
some serious damage in the Battle of
Wakanda in the comics the black dwarf or
as they're calling him in the movie
Kolob Citian leads the attack against
Wakanda so my guess is that Cole
obsidian breaks through the barrier that
will kind of has up cease war machine
doing this damage jumps up and just
smashes the crap out of them and any
falls to the ground could war machine be
one of the Avengers that dies and could
this be that same we'll find out in four
days so that's it on my brief breakdown
of the new trailer that came out today
what do you guys think of all the new
scenes we got in this trailer and what
do you think is going on in these new
scenes let's talk about it in the
comment section below hit the thumbs up
button if you enjoyed this video and
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
do it go thank you so much for watching
woof woof this Friday
[Applause]
[Music]
Avengers infinity war